am 26 wer wüsste es nicht ist europawahl
und um ihren feinden den wind aus den
segeln zu nehmen müsste die eu in
einigen punkten echt mal an sich
arbeiten deshalb unsere neue rubrik
dinge die obwohl die eu wirklich eine
gute sache ist in europa gar nicht mal
so geil laufen heute korruption ja
leider ein echtes problem
das parlament von rumänien hat gerade
ein neues anti korruptionsgesetz
beschlossen
ein korruptions gesetz was am mittwoch
lockerte das parlament per notverordnung
das korruptionsstrafrecht wer besticht
oder den staat beklaut dort künftig kaum
noch bestraft werden wie praktisch ein
neues gesetz damit livio draghi chef der
rumänischen sozialdemokraten mehrfach
vorbestraft nicht in den knast muss er
und seine freunde haben immer wieder eu
subventionen in die eigene tasche
gesucht wobei sich das müssen wir sagen
ja tragen hat auch schon ganz bewusst
projekte aus sucht wo das geld ansonsten
eva klempert wird eines betrifft ein
sozialprojekt für waisenkinder drei habe
dafür gesorgt dass die mittel dort nie
gelandet sein
stattdessen sei das geld an günstlinge
und seine partei gegangen
ja das klingt fies aber was hätten den
waisenkindern mit den ganzen eu
millionen gemacht
süßigkeiten gekauft bukarest wegen des
neuen gesetzes mit harten reaktionen
gedroht kann aber in der praxis fast
nichts machen
außerdem hat rumänien ja gerade die eu
ratspräsidentschaft inne
gesponsert übrigens ausdrücklich kein
witz von coca cola
das heißt bei offiziellen eu treffen in
bukarest ist jetzt alles voll mit zucker
brause logos und ist ein super sports wo
doch die eu gerade über die einführung
einer lebensmittelampel diskutiert ja
wobei das hier ist peinlich ist aber
legale sponsoring keine korruption und
rumäniens politiker stehen ja nicht
alleine da in sachen eu kohle abzweigen
ich sag nur tschechiens andré barbe ja
sehr erfolgreicher mann sehr
erfolgreicher unternehmer mit seinem
konzern agro fährt und als hobby ist
auch noch tschechischer regierungschef
prozent und fast hunderte ineinander
verschachtelte firmen
man nennt andré bisch deshalb schon den
tramp tschechiens seit babbels in der
regierung ist verdoppelten sich fast die
eu-gelder für seine unternehmen bestimmt
zu fall
ja man könnte es auch so zusammenfassen
die eu ist die [ __ ] von david
fördermittel der eu sind zwar eigentlich
zweckgebunden aber gerade so populisten
regierungen wie die von bobic verbitten
sich da jede einmischung
wir sollten darüber entscheiden wie wir
das geld verwenden
wir stellen uns eine andere verteilung
der eu generell vor keinesfalls
akzeptieren will weniger mittel der
einfach weiter überweisen und die fresse
halten größe nicht vergessen wollen wir
an dieser stelle natürlich unseren
lieblings ungarn viktor orban
oder wie enge freunde ihn nennen dem
gulasch mittwoch bei einer einer
milliarde subventionen für ungarn bei
einer milliarde gab es in den letzten
jahren unregelmässigkeiten heißt es also
fragen von eu seite zb die frage warum
kriegt eigentlich orbáns heimatort so
viel kohle
das kann sogar zufällig neben dem
vorgang von eur 1 ferienhaus ein
schickes neues fußballstadion fußläufig
hat das nicht so weit wenn da bald
barcelona spielt ja u bahn hilft halt
gerne auch sein schwiegersohn übrigens
der schwiegersohn ist als kleine
handwerker dank eines einzigen
lukrativen eu auftrags für
straßenbeleuchtung über nacht zum
multimillionär geworden herzlichen
glückwunsch hat sich die hochzeit links
gelohnt
tatsächlich müsste man das geld in
ungarn dringend woanders einsetzen deren
gesundheitssystem ist so marode
die lebenserwartung liegt sechs jahre
unter dem eu-schnitt regierungen wie die
von oben oder von den anderen beiden
machen auf patriotisch schaden aber der
eigenen bevölkerung hier jetzt nicht im
heute-show fanshop karel gott die
subventionierte stimme aus prag sind die
größten osteuropa korruptions sitzt
zig millionen subventionen die sich
lohnen roth si
[Musik]
hitchcock
traumhaft korrupte balladen wie heißt du
die subventionen geht doch egal wie sie
nie wieder sehen
und natürlich sein größter hit
so erreichst euro
doom ist lästiges euro bestellen sie
jetzt nur eine million euro die direkt
an viktor orban schwiegersohn
[Musik]
das geht aus plötzlich nächsthöhere carl
bot sehr guter mann von uns kaputt 13
kritisiert so und wir schalten mal live
zu unserem heutigen brüssel
korrespondent christian ehring hering
was unternimmt die eu denn konkret gegen
solche extremen formen von korruption
jede menge war jede menge dafür gibt es
hier sogar eine eigene behörde die
europäische behörde für den kampf gegen
korruption nennt sich office europäer
blüht und die frau kurz olaf und das ist
natürlich schon teil des problems eine
polizei die oder heißt wie soll man
bitte irgendwas ernst nehmen dass olaf
heißt ich demonstriere das einfach mal
kurz
hände hoch
das spiel ist ausschöpft hier ist und
funktioniert nicht
danke und bitte schön
[Applaus]
die heißen halt so die heißen ja
wirklich so aber was macht olaf denn
kann olaf korrupte politiker vorlagen
verhören verhaften
nein aber die dürfen andere tolle sachen
wie sich befugt jemand zu sanktionieren
der im verdacht steht es um geld
missbraucht zu haben aber unsere
ergebnisse gehen wir weiter die
eu-kommission und dann in island super
oder gegeben dass weiter also wenn die
rausfinden in einem beliebigen korrupten
land nennen wir es aus spaß mal rumänien
sind die politiker kriminell dann ruft
ein after an
und sagt den ja brauchst gekriegt ihr
seid tobt und da sagt der gruppe rumäne
nein echt danke für die info mehr kann
man nicht tun und es kommt noch besser
die eu gründet demnächst sogar eine
eigene staatsanwaltschaft zur
korruptionsbekämpfung ja hab ich gelesen
die soll auch eine frau leiten laura
könnte schien ganz erfahrene
staatsanwälte
ja nee die wird es wohl nicht rumänien
bremst im europäischen rat weil die so
gut ist
die hat ja schon in rumänien jahrelang
korrupte politiker gejagt aus allen
parteien davon zwei ehemalige
ministerpräsidenten und mehrere
amtierende minister insgesamt 70
politiker hat sich vor gericht gebracht
und du kannst natürlich keine frau
nehmen die den job pflegerecht ernst
nimmt ja 1 0 für rumänien ja kurz gesagt
die eu kann überhaupt nichts machen
gegen korruption
doch sie kann menschlich enttäuscht sein
jetzt gucken sie nicht so traurig herr
welke so ist das halt in europa das geld
sucht sich seinen weg wir sind wir denn
diese geldströme zu hinterfragen
dann nehme ich mir doch lieber was mit
dieser live schalte wird ihnen
präsentiert von
europas beliebtestem wettmachen coca
cola damit irgendwann sogar die jogging
hose kneift
[Musik]
guten tag ich könnte ich sie für ein abo
des heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort